[Music]
5 13 on your friday morning what's cool
at school well now you have a chance to
see for yourself that there's so much
more to robotics
than just robots
sure the machines that students design
build
and program
and the competitions they participate in
are what first robotics looks like
seeing the joy they experience tells you
that's not the whole story
angela quick the director of first
nevada first explains the acronym for
inspiration and recognition of science
and technology and quotes the founder of
first dean cayman first is more than
robots the robots are a vehicle for
students to learn important life skills
the competition part involves teams of
robots on a field performing specific
tasks that score the points needed to
keep moving through to the finals with
trips to the world championship on the
line so the ultimate goal every year is
always to get to the first championship
the first championship is basically like
the olympic for robots there's hundreds
of teams from all over the world there
and you get to see some of the best
teams that exist
and that's what you're going to see at
the thomas and mack center starting at 8
this morning until 5 both today and
tomorrow 44 teams 22 from nevada the
rest from all over the country and
around the world including teams from
brazil mexico and turkey learning the
value of teamwork cooperation problem
solving and
yeah having a blast at the same time
you know something that's cool at school
let us know coolant school under the
community tab at eightnewsnow.com or
just email cool at school at
eightnewsnow.com
these young men and women are our future
and they get a lot of help from their
teachers their coaches and volunteer
engineering mentors because they know
nuts and bolts of stuff that you and i
would never even comprehend wow that's
incredible isn't it all the robotics
teams in the valley i feel like we
profile so much of what they do and
every time we show them it kind of blows
my mind yeah they're future nasa
engineers and even if they completely
leave the field they practice what they
teach at first robotics gracious
professionalism so they compete against
one another but if a piece is part of
somebody else's robot somebody says oh i
got that i can help you with that even
if they're on opposing teams oh that is
wonderful and it's just it's amazing
what their young minds can already come
up with conceive and build and problem
solve future's looking bright there you
go gotta wear shades